all right good afternoon i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this afternoon to brief you
on a homicide investigation that we are
conducting
at 1350 north town center
which is an apartment complex directly
behind me near the intersection of
summerlin parkway and town center
the details that i have right now are in
the preliminary stages but at around
11am
we received a report of a for a welfare
check
at an apartment the person calling from
out of state
told us that they had not heard from
their parents in over
a week officers arrived at the apartment
complex
they noticed an odor coming from the
apartment
we obtained a key from the manager and
upon entering the apartment we
discovered the body
of a male and a female that appear to be
a murder-suicide
the female is a white female in her
mid-50s
she appears to have been deceased at
least
a couple days prior to the male being
deceased
so at this point we've learned that the
there were some
financial problems that the couple were
having along with some medical problems
and everything at the scene indicates
that it is a murder suicide
with that i will take a couple questions
it does appear that she was killed
a significant amount of time prior to
her being
or him being deceased so that's it what
we're saying at this point is we believe
she was killed
and then he was in there for at least a
couple
days prior to a self-inflicted gunshot
to himself
do we know if this location has ever had
any type of domestic violence
there's no prior domestics in the last
10 years between this couple
right
say the ladder i'm sorry
yeah yes she has both have
gunshot wounds to each other so
hers is a gunshot wound to the head his
is a self-inflicted gunshot wound to the
head
i'm not going to get into the specifics
of medical conditions i'll just say that
family you know from what we're hearing
is that the couple
was experiencing some financial issues
and medical issues
all right thank you guys
again still early on in the
investigation as far as we will talk to
neighbors in that
as we get on but at this point there's
still nothing that's come up at this
point
all right thank you guys